تصدر محكمه العدل الدوليه في لهاي ظهر
اليوم الجمعه قرارها المتعلق بالتدابير
المؤقته في القضيه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا ضد اسرائيل والتي توجه فيها
اتهاما بارتكاب جريمه باده جماعيه خلال
الحرب التي تواصل شنها على غزه وخلال
الجلسه العلنيه التي ستنعقد اليوم لن
تتناول المحكمه جوهر الدعوه التي ستتطلب
اجراءات للنظر فيها او ستتطلب اجراءات
النظر فيها فتره طويله لكنها ستصدر قرارها
بشان التدابير المؤقته التي طلبت جنوب
افريقيا الاسراع باتخاذها وبينها الحكم
بوقف العمليات العسكريه فورا وضمان عوده
النازحين الى منازلهم وحصولهم على كل
المساعدات
الانسانيه معنا من امام مقر محكمه العدل
الدوليه في هاي مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
بزيان ونور الدين يبدو ان هناك مظاهرات
تستمر امام المحكمه بالتزامن وبانتظار
القرار المرتقب
نعم مياده بانتظار القرار المرتقب على
الساعه الواحده بتوقيت لاهاي خلفي في هذه
المحكمه التي اسستها الامم المتحده العام
1948 ستقف رئيسه المحكمه وهي من جنسيه
امريكيه لتتلو القرار على امام 15 قاضيا
دوليا بالاضافه الى ممثلي كل من جنوب
افريقيا المدعيه واسرائيل المدعه عليها لا
عرف تحديدا كم ستستغرق عمليه تلاوه هذا
البيان لكن لن تقل عن ساعه حسب بعض
المصادر يجب ايضا ان يكون وافق على هذا
القرار او هذه القرارات التي ستصدرها
محكمه العدده الدوليه على الاقل ثمانيه
قضاه بعد ذلك سيعقد او تعقد الاطراف
المعنيه مسؤولون فلسطينيون هناك مبعوثين
فلسطينيان وايضا وزيره الخارجيه لدوله
جنوب افريقيا ستعقد مؤت ممرا صحفيا بعد
معرفه القرار ما يجري الان او ما يسرب من
بعض المعلومات ان المساله الجوهريه لن تبث
فيها هذه المحكمه لانه ليس من صلاحياتها
لكن وفق بعض المحامين والخبراء في القانون
الدولي الذين تحدثنا اليهم يقولون بان ذلك
سيتم ربما بعد سنوات لان الان المطلوب هو
اجراءات استعجال طارئه ومن بين هذه
الاجراءات الاستعجال التي ربما ستعتمدها
المحكمه وردت في الدعوه التي رفعتها جنوب
افريقيا واهمها رفع الحصار وايصال
المساعدات فورا لسكان غزه ووقف ايضا
العمليات العسكريه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
منذ حوالي اربعه اشهر لكن كما تعلمين
مياده كانت اسرائيل اثناء مداولاتها
ودفعتها قالت بانها لن تلتزم بهذه
القرارات وخاصه فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق
النار وبررت ذلك بحجه دائما تكررها وهي
انها تطبق ما تسميه الدفاع عن النفس كما
تعلمين هذه المحكمه لا تعترف بالدفاع عن
النفس مثل ما حدث في العام 2004 عندما
قبلت اسرائيل برفض من قبل هذه المحكمه
التي تقول بان القوه المحتله لا تستطيع ان
تتحجج بهكذا مبدا او موقف على كل حال ما
هو منتظر اذا هو هذا القرار وايضا تبعات
هذا القرار كيف مثلا ستتعافى معهه دوله
جنوب بافريقيا كيف ستتعافى معه اسرائيل
التي تقول بان هذه
المحكمه يعني تبث في موضوع لا يخصها
وتتحدث حتى عن انه لا يوجد بين اسرائيل
وجنوب افريقيا نزاع لكي تبث فيه هذه
المحكمه وايضا الدول الاخرى التي ستكون
ولا شك في وضع حرج اذا اتخذت القرارات
التي لا ينتظرها احد من بين هذه القرارات
مثلا وقف العمليات العسكريه سيطرح مساله
قانونيه واخلاقيه للدول لاحقا اذا خرج هذا
القرار من قبل هذه المحكمه كيف يمكن لهذه
الدول مثلا ان تسمح للشركات بتصدير
الاسلحه وسيعتبر ذلك يعني خرقا للقانون
الدولي اذا اقرت الدوله مثلا
محكمه العدل الدوليه اليوم اذا اقرت نقول
ذلك لاننا لا نعرف لحد الان ما ستقرره
المحكمه ولكن كل ما نعرفه انه ربما يتجه
الامر لحد الان في اقرار اثنين من
الاجراءات اولا قبل كل شيء هو ايصال
المساعدات ووقف استهداف المدن
ون كما شرحت قبل قليل وقف استهداف
المدنيين ربما اسرائيل ستحول ذلك كون انه
سيطلب من
المحكمه من جانب احد فقط لاسرائيل ب ان
تتوقف عن عمليات العمليات العسكريه مياده
شكرا جزيلا لك من امام مقر محكمه العدل
الدوليه في لهاي مراسل الجزيره نور الدين
بوزيان